This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. I fell in love with architecture on the Chicago River. You can endlessly argue about which city has the greatest architecture, but one thing that puts Chicago near the top for me is that the Chicago River provides a beautiful vantage point to take in all the marvelous skyscrapers. Rather than being crammed in on the sidewalk between looming towers, trying and probably failing to take it all in, the river pushes the building to part and gives you the opportunity to coast by on the roof of a ferry, with glass, steel, and concrete wonders presented in their full glory everywhere you turn.
这里是“99%隐形”播客。我是罗曼·马斯。我是在芝加哥河畔爱上建筑的。你可以无休止地争论哪个城市的建筑最伟大，但对我而言，让芝加哥名列前茅的原因之一是，芝加哥河提供了一个绝佳的视角，能将所有奇妙的摩天大楼尽收眼底。河水没有把人挤在耸立的楼宇之间的狭窄人行道上，让你费力却可能一无所获地去打量一切，而是迫使建筑退让开来，让你有机会乘着渡轮的顶篷顺流而下，四周环绕着尽显雄姿的玻璃、钢铁和混凝土奇观。
But probably the city's biggest design achievement isn't a building at all. It's that river itself, a waterway disguised as a remnant of the natural landscape. But it really isn't. It's hard to tell when you see the river, but it's going the wrong way. It should flow into Lake Michigan, but instead, fresh water from Lake Michigan flows backwards into the city. The Chicago River is, in a large part, a carefully designed extension of the city's sewer system, even calling it a river, maybe off base.
但这座城市最伟大的设计成就可能根本不是某栋建筑。而是这条河本身——一条伪装成自然景观残余的水道。但它其实并非如此。当你看到这条河时，很难看出它在倒流。它本该流入密歇根湖，但相反，密歇根湖的淡水却倒流进了这座城市。芝加哥河在很大程度上是该市排污系统经过精心设计的延伸，甚至叫它一条河，可能也名不符实。
It's not really a river, in Chicago, it's really the Chicago Canal. There's not an inch, I don't think, of the Chicago River that is natural in Chicago. That's Richard K. Han. He's a journalist and historian in Chicago. And in 2012, he co-wrote and published a book called The Lost Panoramas, when Chicago changed just river and the land beyond. And it's filled with these gorgeous pictures from before
在芝加哥，它其实不是一条河，而是一条芝加哥运河。我认为，芝加哥河在芝加哥境内没有哪怕一英寸是天然的。这是理查德·K·汉（Richard K. Han）说的。他是芝加哥的一位记者和历史学家。2012年，他联合撰写并出版了一本书，名为《消失的全景：芝加哥如何改变河流与广袤土地》（The Lost Panoramas, When Chicago Changed its River and the Land Beyond）。书中充满了各种精美的照片，拍摄于那个时期之前
and mostly after one of the biggest urban design projects ever, the reversal and the complete transformation of the Chicago River. And that is Dan Weissman, a journalist, lover of triangular buildings, and a lifelong diehard, Chicago. And reversing the river was actually the third in the series of epic design projects,
以及主要拍摄于有史以来最大的城市设计项目之一——芝加哥河的倒流与彻底改造之后。这位是丹·韦斯曼（Dan Weissman），一名记者、三角形建筑爱好者，也是芝加哥的死忠拥趸。而倒流这条河，其实是系列史诗级设计项目中的第三个，
spanning almost 50 years. Three projects that amounted to 19th century engineers just taking it to the laws of nature, with a kind of moxie that just seems to be folded into the DNA of 19th century engineers. And with just the first two, we're talking about two decades of massive, ridiculous achievements, stuff that changed people's ideas of how far you could go to make a city work, and those two have been so obscured by time that the dude who did them, and yeah, it was basically one guy
跨度近50年。这三个项目相当于19th世纪的工程师们直接向自然规律发起挑战，带着一种似乎已经融入19世纪工程师DNA的闯劲。仅仅通过前两个项目，我们就谈论了长达二十年的宏大、荒谬的成就，这些成就改变了人们对“为了让城市运转你能走多远”的看法，而那两个项目被时间掩盖得如此彻底，以至于那个完成它们的人——是的，基本上就是一个人——
who proposed and executed, not one, but two of these incredible projects. He's basically unknown today. Ellis Chesbro. If you've never heard of Ellis Chesbro, you're not alone. In fact, as I record this, he doesn't even have a Wikipedia entry. But you can bet Richard K. Han knows who he is. So he was a star, and his house is just north of downtown, and there's a little plaque
提出并执行了不仅一个、而是两个这样不可思议的项目。他今天基本上籍籍无名。埃利斯·切斯布罗（Ellis Chesbro）。如果你从未听说过埃利斯·切斯布罗，你并不孤单。事实上，在我录制这段音频时，他甚至连维基百科词条都没有。但你可以确信，理查德·K·汉知道他是谁。所以他曾是个大明星，他的房子就在市中心以北，还有一个小牌匾
in front of the house. I once parked my car in front of it. Oh, he's read the plaque. And it says House of Ellis, Chesbro, and I'm sure I'm the only person that ever was very excited about seeing it. Oh, but back in the 1800s, Chesbro was the man, and no one has ever worked harder to save Chicago from its own poop. Poop. The thing that has brought cities to their knees for millennia. Now here's the setup, it's 1854. The city of Chicago had been growing like crazy for a couple of decades.
立在房子前面。我曾经把车停在它前面。哦，他读过那块牌匾。上面写着“埃利斯·切斯布罗之宅”，我敢肯定我是唯一一个看到它会如此兴奋的人。哦，但在19世纪，切斯布罗可是个大人物，没有人比他更努力地拯救芝加哥免受其自身粪便之害了。粪便。几千年来一直让城市屈服的东西。现在背景是这样的，时间是1854年。芝加哥市在过去几十年里疯狂增长。
Out of nothing, huge boomtown, more than doubling its population every few years and then wham. Colour epidemic. Weped out 6% of the city, 6%. That summer, one account had Colour killing 60 people a day in a town of 70,000. One of them was ever put it this way. The death cart was constantly in the street. And not to be gross, but cholera, it is a super nasty way to go. It's sudden, painful and well gross, vomiting, diarrhea, horrible cramps, and you're dead in less than a day,
凭空崛起成为一个巨大的繁荣小镇，每隔几年人口就翻一番多，然后——砰。霍乱疫情。摧毁了该市6%的人口，6%。那个夏天，据一份记载，在一个7万人的小镇里，霍乱每天夺走60人的生命。其中一人这样描述。运尸车在街上络绎不绝。并不是想恶心大家，但霍乱，这真是一种极其痛苦的死法。它突发、痛苦而且确实很恶心，呕吐、腹泻、可怕的痉挛，不到一天你就会丧命，
but it is a really, really unpleasant day. So people were freaking out, Inter-Chezbro, who made a name with Wariky Dunn in Boston. What you people need, he told Chicago, is a sewer system, which was actually a new-ish idea at the time in the U.S. No other city here had one. Sewers yes, systems not so much. And Chicago didn't seem like the town you'd pick to go first. Not if you thought topography meant anything. I mean, Chicago was built on a swamp. Street level, water level?
但这绝对是漫长而极其难熬的一天。所以人们吓坏了，切斯布罗登场了，他在波士顿的沃里克·邓恩（Wariky Dunn）那里打出了名气。他告诉芝加哥：“你们需要的是一套排污系统。”这在当时的美国其实是一个比较新的想法。这里的其他城市都没有。下水道是有的，但系统谈不上。而且芝加哥看起来并不像你会首选的那座城市。除非你认为地形有什么意义。我的意思是，芝加哥是建立在沼泽之上的。街道标高和水位？
Pretty much the same thing. So you put sewers under the street. There's no way for the material in them to, you know, run down hill into anything. So here it comes, round one. The first of these three projects that proved Chicago was ready to try anything. Jasper said,
几乎是一样的。所以你把下水道修在街道下面。里面的东西根本没法，你知道，顺着坡度流进任何地方。所以，第一轮来了。这三个项目中的第一个证明了芝加哥已经准备好尝试任何事情。贾斯珀说，
Okay, let's jack street level up 10 feet. It was a time when engineers were really seen as a savior. And so when he said first off that we're going to build a sewer system, and he said we're going to raise Chicago up 10 feet so that we can put in sores. Everyone's sure, that's great, great idea. Let's do it. Yeah, and there was a reason they went for it. People were making tons of money.
好吧，让我们把街道标高抬高10英尺。那是一个工程师被真正视为救世主的时代。所以当他首先说我们要建造一个排污系统，并且说我们要把芝加哥抬高10英尺以便安装下水道时。每个人都觉得，太棒了，好主意。就这么办。是的，他们全力支持是有原因的。人们在赚大钱。
Chicago's location was perfect, connecting the west to the east, through railroads and the great lakes. And that's why the city was growing so fast to start with. Actually, they didn't jack up the streets themselves. They just piled dirt on top of the old streets to make them higher. And some of that dirt came from the river bottom,
芝加哥的地理位置完美，通过铁路和五大湖将东西方连接起来。这就是为什么这座城市一开始会发展得如此之快。其实，他们并没有把街道本身 jack 起来（用千斤顶顶起）。他们只是在旧街道上堆土把它们垫高。其中一些泥土来自河底，
which they had dredged to make room for all of the old streets to make them higher. And some of that dirt came from the river bottom, which they had dredged to make room for all of the stuff that they were about to dump in there. But they did jack up the buildings. Literally, they put the buildings on jackskrurs, a lot of jackskrurs, and started cranking. There's this great picture from 1857. It shows a massive hotel, big as a city block, at least three or four stories tall,
他们为了给即将倾倒在那里的所有垃圾腾出空间，对河底进行了疏浚。但他们确实把建筑物给 jack 起来了。字面意义上，他们把建筑放在千斤顶上，大量的千斤顶，然后开始摇动。有一张1857年的伟大照片。它显示了一家巨大的酒店，大得像一个街区，至少有三四层楼高，
with dozens and dozens of guys cranking away in perfect sync. Ready, met? Turn! You can also see hotel guests and top hats standing on the balcony as a couple flights up. They're looking out, watching their view get better and better, a quarter inch at a time. And this kind of thing happened over and over again, with businesses staying open while they were getting cranked up, just for kicks. Another fancy hotel had 1200 guys cranking away all at once. Meanwhile, apparently there were teams of mason's laying bricks for a new foundation at
几十个甚至更多的人在完美同步地摇动着千斤顶。准备，开始！转！你还可以看到戴着高顶礼帽的酒店宾客站在高出几层的阳ó台上。他们向外眺望，看着自己的视野变得越来越好，每次提高四分之一英寸。这种事情一次又一次地发生，企业在被摇着上升的同时照常营业，纯粹是为了刺激。另一家豪华酒店有1200人同时摇动千斤顶。与此同时，显然还有一队队的泥瓦匠以最快的速度为新地基砌砖，
top speed, literally working around the guys with the jackskirts. There's another great picture of a huge downtown block of stores and offices getting hoisted up. All 35,000 tons of it. Jacking up the streets and buildings took like 20 years to finish, but by that time Project No. 2 was already done. Because it didn't take too long after the sewers went in. For Chicago to realize that there was a big question that they hadn't given enough thought to on the first go-round. Where did the sewers take all this output? Into the river and where the river go, into the lake and where
字面意义上就是在那些操作千斤顶的人周围工作。还有另一张精彩的照片，展示了市中心一个巨大的商店和办公室街区被整体吊起。整整35,000吨重。抬高街道和建筑花了大约20年才完成，但到那时，2号项目已经完成了。因为下水道投入使用后没过多久，
was the drinking water coming from? Oops. So, okay, said Chasbro, how about this? We'll build water intakes two miles out from shore, way past where the river dumps our muck into the lake. And that'll mean digging the biggest, deepest, longest tunnel ever up to this point. What do you think?
芝加哥人就意识到有一个重大问题他们在第一轮中没有给予足够的重视。下水道把所有这些排泄物都带到了哪里？流进河里，而河又流向哪里？流进湖里，而饮用水又是从哪里来的？哎呀。好吧，切斯布罗说，这样如何？我们在离岸两英里的地方建造取水口，远远超过河水把我们的污物倾倒进湖里的地方。这意味着要修建迄今为止最大、最深、最长的隧道。你们觉得怎么样？
They all said fine and they did it and it was amazing. Again, the city is growing, people are making money, and everybody agrees. They'll do whatever it takes to keep this thing rolling. So it's on round two, digging the tunnels. In 1864, Chesbro's guys start digging the tunnel out from the city, 60 feet down from street level. Year after that, they install a giant structure two miles out in the lake. They call them cribs and start digging a tunnel in from under that, back towards shore. The work went on around the clock from both sides. One crew dug by hand for 16 hours a day. Then a crew of brick layers took the graveyard shift, showing up the area that had just been
大家都说好，于是他们做了，这太神奇了。同样，城市在发展，人们在赚钱，每个人都表示赞同。为了让这一切继续运转，他们愿意付出一切代价。于是进入第二轮，挖掘隧道。1864年，切斯布罗的手下开始从城市向外挖掘隧道，位于街面以下60英尺处。第二年，他们在湖中两英里处安装了一个巨大的结构。他们称之为“围堰（cribs）”，并开始从那下面向回朝岸边挖掘隧道。工作在两侧昼夜不停地进行。一个施工队每天手工挖16小时。然后一队泥瓦匠上夜班，对刚挖好的区域进行加固。
dug out. In November 1865, the two sets of crews met in the middle, just about dead on, centered. You know, this is just all by side. Everybody agreed, Cheshire was a genius and a half. Except they hadn't really solved the problem. The city was still growing like crazy, maybe 200,000 people by 1865, and they were dumping more of their business into the river than ever, which stank. And before the water from the new intakes even started flowing,
1865年11月，两组施工队在中间会合，几乎分毫不差，精准居中。你知道，这完全是题外话。大家都一致认为，切斯布罗是个绝顶天才。只是他们并没有真正解决问题。到1865年，城市仍在疯狂增长，人口可能达到20万，他们把更多的工商业废物倾倒进河里，有史以来最多，臭气熏天。而且在新取水口的水开始流动之前，
the Union stockyards opened on the river's south branch and up the ante. We're talking 320 acres of slaughterhouses and meat-packing plants, all of them dumping whatever they couldn't use and just imagine what that would be into the river. Well, they estimated that the stockyards were the equivalent of a million people's discharges. And there weren't even a million people in the city then.
联合牲畜市场（Union Stockyards）在河的南支流开业了，并且进一步抬高了赌注。我们说的是占地320英亩的屠宰场和肉类加工厂，它们把所有不能利用的东西——试想一下那会是什么——统统倒进河里。好吧，据估计，牲畜市场的排污量相当于一百万人的排泄物。而当时这座城市甚至还没有一百万人。
Yeah, that's true. That bit of the South Fork still goes by the name it got then bubbly creek. All the discarded animal stuff would rot at the bottom of the river and eventually give off methane, which would bubble up to the surface and burst. Also, sometimes it could fire. And sometimes the sewage got swept more than two miles out and found the water in takes.
是的，确实如此。南支流的那一小段至今仍沿用当时的名字——气泡溪（Bubbly Creek）。所有丢弃的动物尸体都在河底腐烂，最终释放出甲烷，甲烷会冒泡浮到水面上并破裂。此外，有时它还会起火。而且有时污水被冲到两英里多远的地方，碰到了水体取水口。
Later they dig these even further out, there's one called the four mile crib. And meanwhile the city kept growing. By 1880, we're talking half a million people and producing more excrement. The stockyards grew too. A lot. One engineer would say Chicago produces more filth per capita than any other city. And now typhoid, what's getting to be a problem?
后来他们把这些取水口挖得更远，有一个叫四英里围堰。与此同时，城市继续发展。到了1880年，我们谈论的是五十万人口，产生更多的排泄物。牲畜市场也扩大了。扩大了很多。一位工程师曾说，芝加哥人均产生的污物比任何其他城市都多。现在伤寒，也正在成为一个问题？
So Chicago started pushing for a new state law to help undertake the biggest, baddest, craziest idea ever. They decided to dig a gigantic new canal that would reverse the river entirely. Reversing the river would bring in fresh water from the lake, and keep Chicago's muck from polluting the drinking water pulled from that same lake, and flush all the sewage down to the Illinois River, which would then take it out to the Mississippi. It took a few years to get the new law approved, the town of Juliet, so a river of crap coming
于是芝加哥开始推动一项新的州法律，以着手实现有史以来最大、最猛、最疯狂的想法。他们决定挖一条崭新的巨型运河，彻底让河流倒流。让河流倒流将引入湖中的新鲜淡水，防止芝加哥的污物污染从同一个湖中抽取饮用水，并将所有污水冲入伊利诺伊河，然后再将其带入密西西比河。新法律的批准花了几年时间，乔利埃特镇（Joliet）眼看一股粪水顺流而下，试图将其否决，然后又花了几年时间制定计划和签订合同。
its way and tried to nix it, and then it took a few more years to get plans laid out and contracts issued. And then it was shovel day, September 3rd, 1892. More than a thousand people came out to watch, and official took one cut with a nickel-plated shovel, and then an engineer detonated two massive loads of dynamite. Dynamite was their preferred weapon against the environment. And it was on round three in the epic struggle against Chicago's own excreta reversing the river. 28 miles of canal price tag 31 million and change in today's money almost 23 billion dollars. As many as 8700 guys working at a time with work work going on year round, tons, and tons
接着就是开挖日，1892年9月3日。一千多人前来观看，一位官员用镀镍铁锹铲了一铲，然后一名工程师引爆了两大包炸药。炸药是他们对抗环境的首选武器。第三轮对抗芝加哥自身排泄物的史诗般斗争开始了：让河流倒流。28英里长的运河，造价3100万美元零一点，按今天的货币计算约为230亿美元。多达8700人同时工作，全年无休，成吨成吨的炸药，
of dynamite, you can hear the blasts downtown when the wind was right. An enormous machine, some invented special for the project, including a 640 foot wide monster conveyor, which broke after less than a year. But still, during the 1893 World's Fair, tourists by the thousands day tripped out to the construction zone. They would take boats and trains out to the site to see the work. And people were coming to Chicago and they were like, you got to see this. You know, this town is amazing and they'll do anything to survive.
风向对的时候，在市中心都能听到爆炸声。一台巨大的机器，有些是专门为该项目发明的，包括一个640英尺宽的巨型输送机，不到一年就坏了。不过尽管如此，在1893年世界博览会期间，成千上万的游客还是日间出游来到施工区。他们坐船和火车去现场参观。人们来到芝加哥，都会说：“你一定要来看看这个。你知道，这个小镇太棒了，为了生存他们什么都肯做。”
Even after the fair closed, train companies ran morning special so local sites seers could check out the big machines and those ever popular dynamite blasts. This was an amazing project. So many people know about the Panama Canal, but it was really in building this canal that they figured out everything, engineering wise and the equipment and a lot of the engineers went to Panama. And then, very late in the game, St. Louis got pissed. We're talking 1899, all the major digging has been done for years, and the fine-tuning
甚至在博览会闭幕后，火车公司还开通了早间专列，以便当地游客参观大型机械和那些大受欢迎的炸药爆炸。这是一个了不起的项目。很多人都知道巴拿马运河，但实际上正是在建造这条运河的过程中，他们在工程学和设备方面摸索出了一切，许多工程师后来都去了巴拿马。然后，在事态发展的很晚阶段，圣路易斯生气了。我们说的是1899年，所有主要的挖掘工作已经进行了多年，微调工作
stuff is getting wrapped up all the construction of bridges and extra digging in the rivers downstream that is going to carry Chicago's water toward the Mississippi and whatnot. And that stuff is very, very close to finished. And this is when St. Louis figures out that all that water carrying who knows what it was headed down the Mississippi Upriver of St. Louis which depends on the river for it's drinking water and for brewing but was your beer The city authorizes its attorney to prepare a lawsuit asking the US Supreme Court for an injunction that would stop the Sanitary District of Chicago from opening up the dams and letting that water go of Chicago from opening up the dams and letting that water go. Thing is, it takes a while to get a lawsuit ready.
即将收尾，桥梁建设和下游河流的额外挖掘工作即将完成，这些工作将把芝加哥的水输送到密西西比河等等。这些工作已经非常非常接近完成。正是在这个时候，圣路易斯发现，所有承载着不知名玩意的河水正朝着圣路易斯上游的密西西比河奔去，而圣路易斯依赖这条河获取饮用水和酿造啤酒——究竟是哪个啤酒厂？该市授权其律所准备起诉，要求美国最高法院发出禁令，阻止芝加哥卫生区的官员打开大坝并放走这些水。问题是，准备诉讼需要时间。
A few months, say, and Chicago starts humping it to get the dams ready to open before St. Louis can get an injunction. So, New Year's Day, 1900, the sanitary district trustees decide the major work is done. The next day, January 2, they head out to a spot on the city's southwest side where there's this one little temporary dam holding back the river from this massive 28 mile canal that's waiting for all that water. The trustees arrive at dawn. One of them bring shovels.
比方说几个月，而芝加哥开始加紧行动，赶在圣路易斯获得禁令之前准备好打开大坝。因此，1900年元旦，卫生区受托人们决定主要工作已经完成。第二天，即1月2日，他们前往城市西南部的一个地点，那里有一座临时小坝，将河水挡在这条等待所有这些水的大型28英里运河之外。受托人们在黎明时分抵达。其中一人带来了铲子。
Most of these projects have these beautiful gold shovels, but one of the trustees just stopped at a high-ware store and bought these kind of tinny old, you know, work shovels. It's like stopping at home depot. Hey, it's five in the morning. I had an awful time getting these shovels this time of day, he says, and he lays them out. There's a couple of reporters there taking notes. And the Trusses dig in, at least they try to.
大多数这类项目都有那些漂亮的黄金铁锹，但其中一位受托人只是在五金店停了一下，买了几把这种看起来很山寨的旧工作铲。就像在家居建材超市停留一样。嘿，现在才早上五点。我这个点弄到这些铲子费了好大劲呢，他说着把它们摆了出来。有几个记者在那里做记录。受托人们开始铲土，至少他们试着这么做。
First off, you should note that it was in January in Chicago, so, you know, you don't shovel anything by hand. The ground was absolutely frozen, and they were going absolutely nowhere. So they bring in a dredge, which also goes nowhere. So they go get some dynamite. Good old dynamite. Which is a dud.
首先，你应该注意到那是1月里的芝加哥，所以，你知道的，你没法用手铲动任何东西。地面完全冻结了，他们根本无处下手。于是他们弄来一台挖泥船，结果也无济于事。于是他们去弄了一些炸药。老牌的炸药。结果是个哑炮。
It doesn't look very promising. There was a lot of profanity. Number one, the trustees can show it out and then the dynamite is not working and then the shovels aren't working. And you know, this was like an insult to the kind of masculinity that we can't even you know open this thing up. A couple hours later it's like 10 in the morning now and maybe a hundred people have gathered and the dredge gets to where I can just get one good scoop and it grabs it.
这看起来很不妙。现场充斥着各种脏话。首先，受托人们大喊大叫，接着炸药不管用，然后铲子也不管用。你知道，这就像是对我们男子气概的一种侮辱——我们甚至连这玩意儿都打不开。几小时后，现在大概是早上十点，可能有一百来人聚集在一起，挖泥船开到了一个地方，刚好可以铲上满满一斗，然后它一把抓住了。
Yeah baby, a few more and a few more and bam everyone's shouting it is open, it is open! Water starts dropping into the canal 24 24 feet straight down, and away it goes. It is the Niagara of Chicago, one of the trustee says. Almost there. But there's still one last dam to open, a bit down the river, which needed the governor's okay. It's a gate that's already been made, so it's just a matter of turning the wheels and control the gate. And once the gate was open, the water could not be stopped all the way down to New Orleans. Meanwhile, St. Louis is still gearing up its lawsuit.
耶，宝贝，再来几斗，再来几斗，然后砰的一声，所有人都在大喊：开了，开了！水开始直往下落，落入24英尺深的运河中，呼啸而去。这是芝加哥的尼亚加拉，其中一位受托人说。快大功告成了。但河下游还有最后一道闸门需要打开，这需要州长的批准。这是一个已经建好的闸门，所以只需转动轮子来控制闸门即可。一旦闸门打开，水流就再也无法阻挡，一直流到新奥尔良。与此同时，圣路易斯仍在加紧筹备诉讼。
There were always worry about St. Louis actually finding a lawsuit that would stop, that would enjoy them from actually opening the floodgates. And to this day, I can't figure out why St. Louis didn't do that. Or why they were so slow about it. Chicago still had to jam a few last pieces into place to get the governor's okay, took two weeks. St. Louis could have filed any day. And then January 17th, the trustees took one more early morning trek to lower the dam. They turned the crank, posed for a picture in their fancy coats and top hats, then beat it back to Chicago for a big lunch. While they were eating, they got word that St. Louis had indeed filed for an injunction that day.
人们总是担心圣路易斯真的会提起诉讼，阻止他们，禁止他们真正打开防洪闸。直到今天，我都搞不懂为什么圣路易斯当时没有那样做。或者为什么他们的行动那么迟缓。芝加哥还得赶着把最后几块拼图拼好以获得州长的批准，花了两个星期。圣路易斯本可以在任何一天提起诉讼。然后到了1月17日，受托人们又进行了一次清晨远足去放下大坝。他们转动曲柄，穿着华丽的大衣和高顶礼帽摆好姿势拍照，然后急忙赶回芝加哥享用丰盛的午餐。正当他们吃饭时，他们接到消息称，圣路易斯确实在当天提起了禁令诉讼。
Too late. They brought a knife to a gunfight. No, they brought a little piece of paper to a torrent of f***ing fight. Late I might add. They waited until just after the fight gates were open. I can't understand that. Legal philosophy. The story made the New York Times, with the headline, The Water in the Chicago River Now Resembles Liquid. St. Louis pushed their case to the US Supreme Court.
太迟了。他们拿了一把小刀去打枪战。不，他们拿了一张纸去对抗奔涌的战局。而且我得说，太晚了。他们一直等到防洪闸打开之后才动手。我无法理解这种法律哲学。这个故事登上了《纽约时报》，头条是：“芝加哥河里的水现在看起来像液体了。”圣路易斯将他们的案件诉至美国最高法院。
Chief Justice Oliver Wendell Holmes noted that, it is a question of the first magnitude, whether the destiny of the great rivers is to be the sewers of the cities along their banks. Which is an important philosophical question, but to paraphrase the way Justice Holmes finished that opinion, whatever man, settling a question that big, it wasn't really the court's job, especially since Missouri allowed St. Louis and other towns to dump sewage into the Mississippi and send it straight to Memphis. So in a very real sense, there was no stopping it.
首席大法官小奥利弗·温德尔·霍姆斯（Oliver Wendell Holmes Jr.）指出：“大河的命运是否就是其流经沿岸城市的下水道，这是一个至关重要的问题。”这是一个重要的哲学问题，但用霍姆斯大法官结束该意见的方式来意译就是：管他的呢，解决这么大的问题其实并不是法院的职责，尤其是考虑到密苏里州允许圣路易斯和其他城镇将污水直接排入密西西比河并直接送往孟菲斯。所以在非常真实的意义上，这是无法阻止的。
The Canal and River reversal was later called a civil engineering monument of the millennium. It was a functional monument to our dominion over the natural world. Or so we thought, fast forward a hundred years to write about now, and the forces of nature are looking for another go-around. There have been some big efforts to clean up the river itself in the last two decades, and by 2015, the treated sewages actually supposed to get disinfected. And when Rich K-Hann and I visited Bubbly Creek looking for bubbles, we may have seen signs of life there instead.
这条运河和河流倒流后来被称为千年的土木工程丰碑。它是我们对自然世界统治地位的功能性丰碑。或者我们曾这么认为，快进一百年到现在的这个时候，大自然的力量正寻找着卷土重来的机会。在过去的二十年里，人们为清理河流本身做出了巨大努力，到2015年，处理后的污水实际上应该会被消毒。当理查德·K·汉和我访问气泡溪寻找气泡时，我们可能在那里看到了生命的迹象。
I see bubbles. Look. I could go with bubbles too. Yeah. I think that's a fish, isn't it? See that? Right down there. I definitely think it's some kind of living thing right there.
我看到气泡了。看。我也能接受气泡。对。我想那是条鱼，对吧？看到那个了吗？就在那下面。我绝对认为那是某种活物，就在那儿。
Yes. Yes, like a guppy. Yeah. Yeah. Oh no, that was a bubble. No, those are bubbles right there. Look at that. But now we're living in a time when the big 19th century interventions in nature seem
对。对，就像一条孔雀鱼。对。哦不，那是气泡。不，那些就是气泡，就在那儿。看那个。但现在我们生活的时代里，19世纪对自然的重大干预似乎
poised of boomerang back at us. Water levels in Lake Michigan have fallen, but at least for now, to the point where gravity may stop pulling lake water into the river, potentially re-reversing the river, if there weren't, you know, engineering interventions. In terms of washing in which Chicago's waste
准备回旋反弹到我们身上。密歇根湖的水位已经下降了，但至少目前，下降到了重力可能停止将湖水拉入河中的程度，如果不进行工程干预的话，河流可能会再次倒流。就冲洗芝加哥废弃物而言，
is mostly a symbolic issue, there are other ways to keep the water and treated sewage flowing away towards the Mississippi. But falling lake levels, I mean, this is most of the fresh water in North America. And a lot of people link this kind of falling lake levels to climate change and the whole catalog of horrors that comes with it. And it all seems like kind of a karmic payback for exactly the kinds of projects that reverse the Chicago River stood for. Yet either we can just do whatever we want to the planet, get away with it.
这主要是一个象征性问题，还有其他方法可以让水和处理后的污水继续向密西西比河流走。但湖水水位下降，我的意思是，这是北美大部分的淡水来源。许多人将这种湖水位下降与气候变化以及随之而来的一系列恐怖事件联系在一起。这一切似乎都像是一种因果报应，报应在正是那些支持芝加哥河倒流的项目上。然而，要么我们可以对这个星球为所欲为却能逃脱惩罚。
And I think that's a completely valid lesson you could take from this. But the inherent hubris involved in reversing a river, or manipulating the environment to suit our needs is exactly what is wrong with us as stewards of this planet. But taking another view. You could also see this as a lesson in the lengths we will go to survive. If we harness that 19th century moxie, the kind of moxie that makes you think that you could and should reverse a river, and we add to that the knowledge we've gained since then. We could guide our best and brightest to engineer the impossible no matter what it takes and we would take day trips
我认为这是一个完全站得住脚的教训，你可以从中汲取。但逆转河流或操纵环境以满足我们需求中所涉及的固有傲慢，正是作为这个星球管家的我们身上最大的错误。但换个角度看。你也可以将其视为关于我们为生存愿意付出多大努力的一课。如果我们利用19世纪的那种闯劲——那种让你认为你能够而且应该逆转一条河流的闯劲，并将我们在那之后获得的知识结合起来。我们可以指引我们最优秀、最聪明的人去设计不可能的事情，无论付出什么代价，我们都会进行一日游
out to the far edge and cheer them on as they save us from getting buried in our own sh**. Or we could produce less sh**, that'd be okay too. ["Fantastic Song"] 99% Invisible was produced as week by Dan Weissman, Sam Greenspan, and me, Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 local public radio, K-A-L-W, in San Francisco, and the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook. I tweet at Roman Mars right now. Oh man, pictures of the Chicago River being reversed. It's amazing. At 99% invisible. invisible. Daughter. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
去到最边缘为他们欢呼，庆祝他们将我们从被自身的粪便埋葬的命运中拯救出来。或者我们少制造点粪便，那也挺好的。["Fantastic Song"] “99%隐形”本周由丹·韦斯曼（Dan Weissman）、萨姆·格林斯潘（Sam Greenspan）和我罗曼·马斯（Roman Mars）制作。我们是旧金山 91.7 本地公共广播电台 KALW 以及旧金山美国建筑师学会的项目。你可以在 Facebook 上找到并点赞本节目。我现在在推特上发消息：@Roman Mars。哦天哪，芝加哥河倒流的照片。太棒了。在 99percentinvisible.org。还没有关于这一集的评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。